you're such an incredible dresser very
fashionable very properly attired and
then is pretty stunning to see the
tattoo that you have on your chest let's
take a look at it right now
it is a gorilla a gorilla wearing a
crown
eating a heart is that correct yeah it's
nice and low-key what made you think of
that no I always hear people talking
about tattoos that they have this kind
of meet a special meaning book yeah I
just like the way it looks for me you
know I wish I could say that it had some
special you know you hear people say
like they have a goldfish on their ass
cheek and it means it's a symbol of hope
or something stupid I've never seen that
before it's certainly original you know
yeah that when you said to the tattoo
guy that's what I want
give me a gorilla crown heating a heart
he's like number 55 few factors in him
like I said earlier my James logo is a
gorilla it's not that particular gorilla
but it is a gorilla so I wanted to kind
of get something along them lines and I
feel like I am the King gorilla so I
stuck the king's crown and I had